- Elle a gardé le sourire
tout en sachant ce qui
l'attendait.
La neuroscientifique
et professeure au départment
de psychologie de l'Université
Concordia, Nadia Chaudhri,
a documenté les derniers mois
de sa vie sur Twitter.
Le diagnostic fatal est tombé
en juin 2020.
- De son lit d'hôpital à l'unité
des soins palliatifs du CUSM,
elle a lancé une collecte
de fonds pour une cause qui lui
tenait à coeur : la bourse
Nadia Chaudhri, destinée
à soutenir les étudiants des
minorités sous-représentées dans
son domaine, en neuroscience.
Plus de 600 000 dollars
ont été amassés auprès
de 8600 donateurs,
un record pour l'université.
JOELLE MALEK, infirmière
Institut de recherche du CUSM
- Elle a quand même un jeune
enfant, un mari, mais elle s'est
battue pour laisser quelque
chose pour les autres.
- Pour sa médecin, son histoire
permet également de sensibiliser
les femmes aux cancer
des ovaires, un cancer
difficile à détecter.
DIEGO MÉNA, VP, engagement de la
Société canadienne du cancer
- Des fois, quand on a des
symptômes, c'est déjà un peu
trop tard. Donc, il faut quand
même parler au medecin,
le médecin va être plus,
en fait, en mesure de voir si
on a des antécédents familiaux,
si on a des facteurs de risque.
- Le message le plus important
pour la médecin qui
l'a suivie :
- Nadia Chaudhri a vécu à fond
jusqu'au dernier moment.
Les drapeaux de l'Université
Concordia ont été mis
en berne.
ICI Mélissa François,